the worst air quality ever recorded in
New York City if you look at the
pictures it's it's bright orange there
it's weird it's crazy and hazy the
wildest reaction to this came from some
yuppies yesterday at equinox The Equinox
is a fancy gem for Rich urbanites and
and the picture was taken and published
I think by the New York Times but it was
taken of this rooftop of some building
in New York where amid all the haze the
dangerous air quality there are a bunch
of wealthy young New Yorkers
standing doing some kind of yoga
salutation standing up arms in the air
like a religious worship ceremony
which is exactly what yoga is if you
were an anthropologist you were an
historian and you came across this
picture
500 years into the future you would say
oh this is an example of religion in
2023 New York